Hi there.
So I released,
this is the third of three videos that
I'm releasing this morning.
And the first one deep,
I just read the letter from the
university administration requesting my
silence.
And then in the second one I detailed
out my response and said that I was
going to meet with the dean of the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences,
David Cameron.
And I had gone to meet with David on
Friday to discuss what had happened and
to discuss the letter.
And we had a good meeting,
we had a good meeting and he's a
reasonable person.
And,
uh,
so I suggested because I thought before
the meeting and I talked to my family,
I thought,
well,
what's the best possible way this could
move forward so that it would be in
everyone's best interest,
mine and the universities and the
broader public and the students and,
and everyone.
And so we thought that the best thing to
happen would be that the university
could agree to host a,
um,
a debate,
a public debate about the issue about
bill see 16 and about legislation like
it and that,
that,
that would be officially hosted by the
university and I could present my case
and whoever wanted to present their case
contrary to what I've been stating would
be invited to.
And so the Dean,
David Cameron said that he had to talk
to some people and that he would get
back to me as soon as possible.
And so over the weekend he talked to
mark Gertler,
who's the president of the university
and the provost,
sheryl red air and the vp of hr,
Kelly,
Hannah Moffitt.
And they agreed to go forward with it.
And so I was thrilled and I still am
thrilled and,
and so good because that means,
you know,
one of the things we talked about was
that we could talk about this,
like civilized human beings and we could
discuss the real issues here.
And maybe as well we could use the
University of Toronto as a model to all
universities who've been dealing with
this sort of thing too,
about how to actually deal with it.
Like,
like people who are rational and
intelligent and careful and thoughtful
in all of that.
And so they agreed to the public debate
and we talked about two other issues.
One was they were concerned during the
meeting about the possibility of
security violations,
you know,
demonstrations and that sort of thing.
And so they thought for a while about
only holding it online,
but they decided not to do that,
to do it as,
as a university function live,
which is exactly right.
And we talked about security concerns
and,
and agreed at least tentatively that the
rule would be that unwarranted
disruptions will be stopped.
So that because both sides are going to
be represented in this debate and,
and I hope they can find someone
articulate and intelligent to make a
case for the other side because that's
what we want.
So anyways,
look,
this is unbelievably good news.
It's unbelievably good news because it
means that the university has decided to
uphold its position as an investigator
into complex intellectual matters.
And that we can discuss this like with
like civilized human beings.
And so my Kudos to the University of
Toronto,
and you know,
I've said from the beginning that this
is an institute that I've respected and
admired and I'm grateful to for,
for providing me with the position that
I have.
And I am so absolutely thrilled that
they decided to do the right thing.
And not only that,
and I got to tell you,
and this is God's honest truth,
David thanked me for bringing the issues
to their attention.
And he meant it.
So hurray.
It's so good.
So strike one.
You know,
Mark went up on the wall for free speech
and for the University of Toronto.
So,
and I'd like to thank all the people
that have been supporting me.
It's been very helpful and your letters
were very useful.
And you know,
we can talk,
we can talk these things through.
So let's do it.
Excellent.
Bye.
Okay.